welcome to this video playing renegade
from Canada hmm Kings Indian I came I
want some quiet life if he yeah I'll do
that
it's some not the most aggressive or
interesting line but it's a it's very
safe and have won numerous games with it
it's not them
so easy so black Joe to defend this yeah
one of the possibilities rupee eight
long castle yep
I've got Luke d8 rookie five is not
really helping we can play Knight a six
now um or h6h six was played by by dr.
nun recently and I won a nice game at
least I liked it okay let's see what
happens now Knight to c5 a sir now the
the normal move h6 now I can drop back
to e3 this is also difference to the
Bishop e2 exchange this h3 pawn
sometimes can be really useful okay
in the Adam only he cannot take on e4
three times because at the end I've got
work to do okay so with this movie
basically says yeah okay I'm a pawn down
and play for compensation now let's see
if he really gets this compensation
and now I could even go f4 or is this
somehow too much taking space yeah I saw
this but the thought just g4 and what
does this thing doing on IG 3 I can take
everyone and I can take care for but f5
I'm threatening f5 then wait not so not
so quickly all this can I go
let's let's start with a developing
movement once in a while it's not too
bad to develop no threatening jeev form
and if he goes Knight g3 rookie one i'm
nicely centralized and this night can
easily be attacked with bishop f2 yeah
what I need to do is I need to make sure
that this is all nicely protected the d3
Bishop for example if I go Bishop f2 oh
this is interesting
he fibers is probably see me
he's probably intending to play g5 so ii
v g5 but I have made f3 yeah
okay then I should the nurse should
accept this challenge I also could have
taken on f5 it's not a knight f5 okay
yeah this is the more principled term
anyway yeah if he doesn't do that it's
it's completely pointless so we must
play g5 now and no probably not
h5 and Bishop g5 this was my my
calculation that he now needs to drop
back and now more than one interesting
idea g4 Nanji for us not on 92 assessor
completely a 92 three maybe he can just
take a 5 so very shaky g4 is not
protected other ones g4 would be now
it's just trapping this for this night I
cannot really prepare this I don't see
how our weights not deform maybe 94 is
good yeah
this looks like a good move actually
just intending to take on the e6 and f5
this is strong I think
maybe 95 I 95 I maybe can even just take
take bishop take 96 rookie six Bishop f5
and and I'm winning back at least the
exchange with an extra pawn at the end
me Knight e5 Knight is six this may be
93 you don't like so much
yeah hard hard to give him any advice
yeah it's I don't really see a move yeah
then now I go to H I don't really want
to go here neither force not I don't
want the night on her form at any stage
this looks simple I mean aged six didn't
help him so much just take it yeah come
on
maybe you can take d3 I'm gonna have and
now I have the G form this is yeah okay
I'm a bit lucky that this is all working
so nicely trapping the night I didn't
see that
now the the rook is protecting g3 this
was okay it's okay
but I can take can take both both pieces
rock you ain't no coming ninety five six
is nice yeah rook to f8 it's a good idea
Jenny yeah almost wouldn't really better
to give the chick first it doesn't make
a difference really look son yeah
Mitnick smooth energy follows him was
the key move maybe I don't think really
help me had enough of the pawn this
looks really really ugly how Bishop h6
seems to be good yeah Bishop h6 I didn't
see that 92 is what the computer wants
to play just fetch 92 how ugly can you
play 92 but g4 has a threat Bishop h6
not strong so just oops was too much
here
this is a good move
yeah and this is black has got some
activity him do something like this
b3 yeah hard to tell but at least it
looks like black is actor it's not
necessarily mean that he's good but it's
his active not the same in the gamer
think after after this oops keep hitting
this wrong thing here if he doesn't play
g5 it's just busted and g5 okay needed
needed to try that is mad before exactly
I'm 94 was strong glad that I spotted
that wasn't sure at first how to
continue thanks for watching